their arrival on the horizon marks the
final minutes
of months of travelling this is the
first time we've watched this whole
journey
unfold in real time finally
stepping onto british soil this beach
represents a long-awaited
success as they wait in the blistering
sun
their trusted vessel stands a lonely
figure on the shore
it tells a story of their illegal yet
perilous trip
this second boat carried women and
children
their new surroundings may be
intimidating but there is no
understating their relief a family of
six among the dozens we met
whereabouts originally eritrea
eritrea did you cover your own or with
family
how does it feel to be here
how does it feel now to be here he's
really happy
what what now what's the plan
we i don't know but
i have a lot of things to do first
first of all i have a family to feed
and then i came here to
continue my education what were you
doing back in iran
iran they prevented me to do anything
we watched as they were questioned one
by one by border force officials
names ages nationalities sky news would
normally not be able to film this
process so closely
it's an insight we have rarely seen
there is exhaustion written on their
faces
the desperation is clear to see the
beach here at dungeness
is the front line of the so-called
migrant crisis
after months of travelling having left
their home nations behind
they've reached their final destination
but it's not over yet
they will now look to claim asylum it
could take years to get their new
identity
but their arrival couldn't be more
timely 80 miles away their future is
being debated
the home office today pitching their
tough stance on reforming
the uk's asylum system the public
expects this house to protect our
borders
they expect us to combat the dinghies
crossing the english channel
and they expect us to remove those with
no right to be here
this bill will deliver those people's
priorities
some argue the crackdown addresses the
symptoms of the problems
while ignoring the underlying issues
that have caused people to flee
but as long as these british waters
symbolize hope and new beginnings
they will keep on coming ashnaharanak
sky news
dungeness in kent